hey everybody this is David Petty I'm a
chess expert and I'm here for the chess
comm YouTube channel to talk about the
three phases of a chess game and before
I do that I want to talk about generally
goals in chess and when you're playing
along in your game it's good to keep in
mind what you're trying to accomplish in
different positions what your goal is
and some goals are the same no matter
what part of the game you're in for
example it's always good to try to
checkmate the enemy king if you can or
to take a free piece if you can get away
with it but other goals depend on maybe
the specific position or what phase of
the game you're in
and when I say phase what I mean is a
chess game is like a story and every
story has three parts a beginning a
middle and an end so like a story just
about every chess game has three parts
the beginning which is the opening the
middle which is called the middle game
and the end which is called the endgame
and the strategy and the goals of the
different parts of the game are very
different from each other
now of course not every single chess
game has all three of these parts for
example here's a chess game that only
goes two moves and ends in the opening
this game never had a middle game it
never had an endgame and it barely had
an opening right because checkmate
happen right away this is the fastest
checkmate possible but most games will
not end instantly like this and they'll
have an opening a middle game and an
endgame so now I just want to give a
brief overview of what the strategic
goals are in the opening the middle game
and the endgame so the opening is all
about developing your pieces getting
your guys out to do anything in a chess
game you're going to have to use your
pieces right I mean you can't just do
everything with your King you have to go
out with your army and accomplish things
and right now at the start of the game
and this
your pieces are pretty bad every chess
piece has a certain potential for how
many squares it could control if it were
at its most powerful for example here
the bishop has how many different
squares that it can move to well it has
13 squares so this Bishop is doing
fantastic it can move to as many squares
as it ever possibly could and that is a
good Bishop likewise this rook here is
doing pretty well how many squares can a
rook move to on an empty board very good
rook can move to 14 squares on an empty
board 7 along the file and 7 along the
rank a queen the most powerful piece can
move to a total of 27 squares when she's
at her maximum potential right you can
barely see the Queen here because she's
got so many arrows shooting out of her
and the knight can move up to eight
squares when it's at its maximum
potential but at the start of the game
here how many squares can your bishop
move to out of its possible 13 hmm zero
right the bishop can't move how many
squares can the rook move to zero right
your queen
the most powerful piece has a total of
zero squares out of 27 that she could
possibly move to she can only move to
zero right so your pieces at the start
of the game or it kind of like you know
0% power or maybe like 5% power the
Knights doing like okay because he can
move to two squares but that's still
only 25% right one quarter of the eight
squares he could potentially move to so
the goal of the opening is to kind of
wake your pieces up bring them out and
help them to attack squares and kind of
live up to their full potential so an
excellent first move in the game is the
move pawn to e4 because it activates
three
of your pieces well to a lot and one
just a little bit how many different
squares did your pieces gain access to
from that move count them up really
quickly all right your pieces gained
access to 11 new squares four squares
for the Queen this way
five squares for the bishop on this
diagonal and one new square each for the
king and the knight right the king of
the knight can both go to e2 as well so
that's 11 new squares for your pieces to
move to from just one pawn move that's
an amazing first move giving you a whole
bunch of new options that you didn't
have before compare this first move
efore to the move h6 by black this is an
atrocious move because it doesn't really
help you to activate your pieces it's
true it gives your rook one new square
but first of all even if you move your
rook to this h7 square he doesn't
improve right he still only has one
square you can kind of move back and
forth and he's not getting any better
right secondly even if you gain one
square for your rook you took away one
square from your knight so the sort of
total number of squares you've gained
access to for all your pieces is zero
right plus one for your rook minus one
figure Knight this would be a bad way to
improve your pieces and help them reach
their potential so let's say white plays
another good move and that would be the
move for example Bishop to c4 now why is
that a good move your Bishop was already
controlling how many squares good your
Bishop was attacking five squares right
and after you move him out to c4
he's still controlling those five
squares on the diagonal but he also
gains access to a new diagonal over here
gaining four new squares so he used to
be able to move to five squares now he
can move to a total of
9 so that's almost doubling the power or
the sort of reach of the bishop so that
is a very good move its called improving
your bishop or that we use the word in
chess developing him okay now another
principle for the opening is that it's
good to improve your pieces but you
don't want to spend too much time just
improving one piece for example you
could move your Bishop back to be three
and that would technically improve him a
little bit because on the c-4 square he
was not being defended by anybody and on
the b3 square he is right that makes him
a little bit safer but that's a very
minor improvement for the bishop and it
would have been a lot better to instead
improve one of your other pieces for
example if you play the move d4 you're
giving the other bishop a whole new
diagonal to work on right he gains
access to five new squares which is a
lot better than just protecting one
piece that wasn't even under attack so
it's good to help your pieces realize
more of their full potential but it's
also good to spend about one move on
each piece and then move on to the next
piece because the amount you can improve
this bishop here which is like at 0%
versus this Bishop which is already at
like 75% power there's a lot more you
can improve this guy by a lot more than
you can improve this guy now three more
quick principles about the opening the
first one is that we like to control the
center of the board and we're going to
have a lesson on the center on a
different time on the YouTube channel
but the long and short of it is this the
center is the crossroads of the
chessboard right a lot of different
files ranks and diagonals shoot through
the center from the center your pieces
can move in any direction and go to any
sort of side of the board if you have a
knight here in the middle of the board
and the action is over here on the Kings
side then I can hop over there quickly
and join the fight if you have a fight
over here then I can quickly hop over to
that side and join the fight over there
so it's very flexible to have your
pieces in the center
number two is that you don't want to
make a lot of pawn moves in the opening
and if you think about it in terms of
improving your pieces how many squares
do your pawns control at the start of
the game exactly they control two
squares right and what is the maximum
number of squares upon can ever control
a pawn can only ever control two squares
right if we move our pawn to e4 well
it's nice that we put our pawn in the
center but he still is only controlling
two squares it's true that the quality
of the squares that he's controlling is
gotten better because now he's attacking
squares in the center and helping us
control an area of the board that we
want to control but still he was already
controlling two squares back at home
right so there's not as much to gain by
pushing your pawns out the main thing
you gain by pushing your pawns forward
is releasing your pieces so you only
need to make two pawn moves to get all
your pieces out you move your two Center
pawns like this for example and that
releases both of your bishops your
Knights can come out by themselves
because they jump the Queen doesn't have
to go out too far at the start of the
game and then the last principle of the
opening is that you want to get castled
and we say that the opening is over when
you've castled your King you've
developed all of your minor pieces your
bishops and your Knights and your rooks
are connected that means your books are
sort of attacking each other here and
looking at each other and this would be
a perfect opening for white developing
all of his pieces meanwhile black was I
don't know jumping as knight back and
forth in circles and not making any
progress this would be a perfect setup
for white in the opening now here is a
sample middle game position that I sort
of invented and it vaguely resembles or
right Lopes but the middle game is kind
of the largest and hardest to define of
the three parts of the game but in
general what you're trying to do in the
middle game is two things you're trying
to take pieces you're trying to win
material take more of their guys than
they can take of yours and number two is
sometimes you make checkmating attacks
against their king okay you can also try
to
saddle them with weaknesses but that's a
little bit of an advanced concept so to
aid you in winning material which is the
really the main thing that happens in
the middle game is that you trade pieces
and you try to get more there's all
sorts of things called tactics like
forks pins skewers discovered attacks
and those things are in our chests
tactics section on our chests comm
YouTube channel so you can look up those
things those are tools to help you in
material but basically in the middle
game you fight for a while and trade off
pieces and you reach the endgame when
you've traded enough pieces for your
King to be brave enough to come out from
his castle and fight so the endgame is
really different in that the rules of
some of your pieces changed drastically
and those two pieces are your pawns and
your king a big thing about the endgame
is that your King is now able to come
out into the game and join right the
king we never tried to activate him at
the start of the game because if you
activate your King by running into the
middle where he's strongest then you get
checkmated because there's too many
enemy pieces running around but in the
endgame when we've traded off pieces
with only a couple pieces left the King
comes out in fights
so we centralize our King and the other
thing we try to do is create and promote
passed pawns so a passed pawn is like
this pawn because no enemy pawn can halt
him in his advance to the other side of
the board when a pawn reaches the end of
the board it can be promoted and so that
is the goal of the endgame you activate
your King and all your pieces of course
and you try to promote your pawns and
this is a passed pawn for white because
only the enemy pieces but not pawns can
stop him and this would be a passed pawn
for black for the same reason so there
you have it in the opening you try to
bring out your pieces control the center
and castle your King once you've done
those things you enter the middle game
where you try to win material and make
favorable trades and you reach the
endgame when enough pieces have been
traded off for your king to be activate
and you try to promote your pawns and
ultimately when you have a big enough
material lead you promote your pawn into
a queen and you go checkmate the enemy
king and those are the three phases of
the game and the corresponding general
strategies and goals to go with them I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm